yes just to confirm that's an elephant
fire 12 is and 20,000 happy meals to be
delivered by 4 p.m.
yeah I really need them here before
otherwise I'm going to have a real hard
time driving a bunch of viewers so if
you can just confirm that they're going
to be here at 4 hey um I'm doing it
today I'm back okay yes you you just
week that's right you know it was it was
so hey she's gonna be sick I need to
cancel all of that first up it's been a
good while since we've been able to get
the pitchforks out over a resolution but
minecraft on switch is here to fix all
that the popular sandbox building game
was released last week for switch and
was found to run in 720p in both docked
and undocked mode Microsoft
representative offered an explanation to
time saying it's not a question of
system power rather the issues that stem
from quote shifting from one resolution
to the other when docking and undocking
they added that it's possible but not
confirmed to that minecraft force which
could hit 1080p docked at some point in
the future if you're wondering why I
keep referencing Microsoft you may
remember they bought minecraft for a
cool 2.5 billion back in 2014
next up Sega has revealed its roadmap to
2020 and a plan to revive some of its
older IPs
sega sammy the Consolidated holding
company formed after the merger of sega
and sammy has shared plans for the
future as part of its road to 2020
presentation stick with me I promise it
gets more interesting the company
outlined plans to double down on
existing properties and look to obtain
new ones for North American and European
PC games Sega's Japanese Studios will
focus on major franchises such as
fantasy star Puyo Puyo and persona while
the North American studios will work on
Sonic Company of Heroes and dawn of war
over in Europe the focus will be on
football manager the strategy series
endless and total war Sega also revealed
plans to revive old major IPs though
unfortunately they didn't go into
details but we can't speculate let me
know down in that comment section what
you want to see make a reappearance
that's the dead not you Dan the viewers
finally The Legend of Zelda is coming to
your phone maybe if you enjoyed the
lakhs of Super Mario run or Fire Emblem
Heroes for something a little more niche
Nintendo might be delivering another
mobile game before the year is out
sources have told The Wall Street
Journal that a phone version of Zelda
will launch after the release of the
Animal Crossing mobile game later this
year if you're wondering exactly when
that is we also don't know that yet we
don't know a lot of things the report
also mentions that the Pokemon company
which Nintendo has a 32% deck in is
making a new card based Pokemon game for
mobile devices of course neither the
Pokemon company nor Nintendo have
commented on these rumors but given the
success of their previous mobile games
it's not a huge stretch to believe that
these games might be on the way that is
everything I've got for you today do let
me know down in that comment box where
you cared about and I will see you again
tomorrow there's someone here with
20,000 happy meals what did you do